samuel apparently you have recently lost
your title
as the highest grossing actor of all
time yeah
i've been displaced by harrison ford
again i displaced him he displaced me
but hey it's only 70 mil
yeah it's like a weekend i got them
covered in july
he's lucky i'm not in captain america 3
now
have you seen the new star wars yeah
okay all right
moving on it would have been better with
you in it yeah that's really yeah
that's that's the bottom line or more
popular anyway
it couldn't be more popular yes it could
have i haven't seen it and i would have
watched it a few reasons i see right
there
right there yeah but you do watch all
your films is is right yes i do
like more religiously i do
i watch them at home i i go to the
theater i know
when i have a movie that's opening i
know it's going to make
at least a thousand dollars that weekend
because i buy thousand dollars worth of
tickets
and i give them to the church or i give
them to somebody and their kids go
but i i go in the movie after the
movie's been open for a moment
you know to see what normal people are
seeing or doing while they're watching
the film to see how they react to it
when you go to a premiere i mean
everybody's had to kiss your ass you
know come on here
they're gonna love the movie oh my god
you are amazing you know and you go with
some regular people they go out of
movies this
movie sucked yeah but sam jackson was
just [__] he's always the [__]
yeah i go i like it and if i'm sitting
at home
and if i'm you know if i'm channel
surfing there's nothing else on
i i go into the search engine and go
samuel jackson boom
you